woman: A good rating is vital
to your app's success.
Users are more likely to
download a well-rated app.
We've compiled ten key tips
to increase your app's rating.
Read and understand Android's
creative vision
on the Android Developer's
website.
By embodying the principles
in your app,
you will enchant the user,
simplify their life,
and make them amazing.
Make your design your own.
Great design comes from
understanding your users
but still pushing
the boundaries.
Material Design
is a design ethos
for a multi-screen world.
It provides
a comprehensive guide
for visual, motion,
and interaction design
across all form factors
and devices.
Get started at
Google/com/design.
A great smartphone app
doesn't necessarily equal
a great tablet or Wear
or TV app.
Don't copy your app
to other form factors.
Adapt it to each use case.
A tablet user will immerse
themselves in your app,
so make use of that
extra screen space.
Your Wear user will want
timely information.
Focus on specific actions that
would be useful then and there.
Elegant, usable, high-rated apps
are most often simple too.
Look critically at your menus
and action buttons
and focus on what your user
will really want
and really need to do.
The quality guidelines
will provide you
with a minimum starting point
for your app testing.
By exercising these tests
for each form factor
your app supports, you can
ensure your app hits
the essential requirements
every great Android app
is built on.
You should test your app on as
many real devices as possible.
The Google Cloud Test Lab
can help with the devices
you can't get your hands on.
Sign up in the Developer Console
to receive test reports
for your alpha and beta apps.
These reports will help you
understand
the results of loading
and interacting
with your app on popular
physical devices
from different geographies.
Source your testers,
key members of your
user community,
those who are keen to feedback.
Then use the beta testing
feature
of your Developer Console
to distribute your test app
so that you can start gathering
their feedback.
Asking users to sign in too soon
can be a turn-off.
Let them appreciate what your
app has to offer first.
Have them sign in
when it makes sense,
such as for saving content,
personalization,
cross-device functionality,
and more.
The Developer Console lets you
read users' reviews
and reply to them too.
The reviews can help you
understand the top problems
that users have with your app.
Respond, acknowledge, fix.
Let them know if the fix won't
be an instant update.
Earn a loyal following.
Your app ratings will reflect
this mutual respect.
Keep an eye on reasons
for crashes or freezes
with the information provided
in the Developer Console.
Monitor this information closely
and fix any issues as quickly
as possible.
A high app rating and great
reviews will pay dividends,
encouraging others to download
and engage with your app.
For more information, head over
to the Distribute section
of the Android Developer
website.
If you want more tips on
how to improve
your app or game's performance
and build a better app business,
check out the other videos
in this series
and download the secrets
to app success on Google Play.